hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so for those who don't
know me yet i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now i'm doing some youtube
videos where i'll show you guys how i
use
mostly technical analysis to build my
scenarios and to set up my trades so in
today's video i want to make an update
on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
okay guys so let me just sum up a bit
the situation
so i've done my last video around i did
one here
i told you guys were breaking out and i
did my last video around here and i told
you guys that we are bullish
so what i'm actually doing here guys you
need to understand
this because this is actually the most
important thing
about the way i use technical analysis
is that i'm counting waves and i'm
trying to see
whether or not the wave is complete and
where
possibly the next wave is going to so
here very quickly guys i use idiot waves
counting you have
different theories of counting but iliot
is the best one
is the one that is the most successful
and that most traders are using
so very quickly waves up developing five
waves
one two three four five and waves down
develop in
three waves usually abc can be also a
triangle and
abc waves are actually the most common
ones so here i have my one
that i broke down in five waves and the
question i'm having so this is the very
this is the most important thing about
the videos i'm doing an amc
for the past week and maybe for the next
week as well
is where is the second wave going all
right then three
four five would go like here probably so
this is my target
the third wave going to 25 then
correcting and then we go to 2d5 alright
but to do that we must first complete
the second wave so we have different
ways
to actually spot if a wave is complete
or not
and the one i prefer is so let me get
rid of it is to use trend lines so this
is
what i showed you guys already so i do
it very quickly again i connect the
height that i have here with the height
that i have here
and this connection gives me a trend
line that once
is broken is usually retested exactly
like we did here
and then usually we go higher so this is
my preferred scenario all right so this
is what is probably happening
uh right now but once again you cannot
build up your scenarios just
by you know using one method and
concluding right away that
this is my preferred scenario you need
to have more methods that are actually
converging to the same conclusion
so here first i need to analyze if my
second wave is clean or not
so i know this is a corrective wave abc
so i try to label it
so a very easy
b very easy and the question is
is the c wave going here is the c wave
going here
so i'm going to build up a few scenarios
let's say the c wave
first is going here so this is something
i showed you guys already
and then we're having a one two
and then we must be in this you know
third wave
so let me do this
all right this is what we are looking
for guys this is
the scenario that to me you know is the
most likely but
i want to show you guys the other
scenarios that we could have
so you guys are prepared to everything
but for now
this is you know really looking
good to me it looks like you know very
normal here we have an abc so
it looks like we are in the third wave
of
our third wave so we are looking for a
very impulsive
move coming very soon guys very soon
and let me show you the alternative
scenarios
depending on what the price action is
doing we know
what is happening so for example here
the alternative scenarios because
you're not sure that you know it's not
because we don't do the third wave right
now that actually the third wave
won't happen the third wave would happen
i think anyway
the question is when so this is the
alternative scenario
up so i do like this and it's actually
not an abc
it's a wxy
w x
y and in my w x y guys
same this is in the book so we having
abc
we're having a b c so it's abc abc abc
and here look guys i'm gonna give you
some very precious information
right now and then the b wave so is it
like this maybe maybe but
we having here a breakout so we probably
gonna go higher
so what is the maximum level we can go
to for this scenario to be still valid
we can only go guys up
to the maximum that we have here
for this bearish scenario to actually be
valid so if we see amc trading above
11 30 we know that this scenario is
actually
off the table so this is a very precious
information all right
if we go above 11 30 we are 90
sure that we are in this third wave and
the third wave
will be impulsive if everything that i
said before is correct
of course but you know i've been going
through the stuff
many many times and i i believe that
everything that
has been done on my charts in my
drawings using idiot wave theory is
accurate so let's suppose i'm right on
this
so if we go above 11 30 this scenario is
of
the table so once again here
we could also see something like this
a b c i'm not gonna do all of them but
maybe
we are not doing a one two three four
five but an abc
and we're gonna have one more all right
so this is the second scenario
that to me is less likely actually to
happen
and to know that i use actually other
techniques
that i'm gonna show you in a video that
i'm publishing i think
in the same time i'm gonna do it right
away it's about divergences all right so
i use divergences to help me
to actually pick up my scenario here my
preferred scenario is definitely
the first one so my first scenario i
remember you guys was like this
and that here we were doing a one two
three four five
and i think that this is my perfect
scenario because actually i'm having
some nice divergences that i'm going to
show you in another
video so guys that's it for me i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys